tarik birgit tara il ya quatre membres
d'une même famille et le même passion la
danse
une découverte toute nouvelle pour eux
leurs premiers pas de danse sportive
ils les font il ya seulement trois ans
j'ai tout d'abord fait des sports tél le
rugby ou le football je me passais par
le handball
et puis ensuite j'ai décidé de
développer beaucoup plus mon côté
artistique et donc nous voilà et je dois
dire que
je préfère dix fois le côté artistique
au côté brut ou au côté très physique du
handball bien sûr la danse est un sport
physique aussi mais dans un autre sens
c'est plus de la concentration ce qui
plaît avant tout c'est des moments qu'on
passe ensemble c'est vraiment une
activité familiale est donc un partage
très fort on partage beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de plaisir beaucoup de passion
parfois un peu d'énervement aussi c'est
voilà c'est mais c'est avant tout un
moment un moment à passer ensemble une
passion devenue dévorante birgit et la
présidente de leur club le duo dance
club de colomb tariq en est le vice
président ils pratiquent tous les quatre
des danses standards et latines
[Musique]
nous dans la famille pour l'instant on
aime vraiment les deux ont donc on aime
les dix danses dans les standards et
latines et pour l'instant on n'a fait
aucun choix
il est probable avec l'âge en général
que les seniors en minéral à un moment
se concentre plus sur les dents standard
que sur les dents statines
si tarik et birgit sont en couple tard
iam son frère et soeur un avantage pour
eux les avantage c'est qu'on peut se
voir tout le temps on a forcément on est
plus familier donc avec l'autre plus il
ya moins de chaînes de poser les mains
quelque part que si c'était quelqu'un
qu'on connaissait pas bon après on parle
bien sûr on dit des choses bien plus
naturellement parfois des choses
l'exemple l'un à l'autre parce que
forcément on se connaît mieux mais sinon
on est très réserve c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment extraordinaire ce dimanche il
participait à une épreuve qualificative
de coupe de france
tara il ya donc un millier deuxième du
concours de danses standards et vise
l'international
[Musique]